Welcome back to six as zero,
nine for deep learning for self driving
cars.
Today we will talk about autonomous
vehicles,
also referred to as driverless cars,
autonomous cars,
robot cars.
First,
the Utopian view where for many
autonomous vehicles have the opportunity
to transform our society into a positive
direction.
One point 3 million people die every
year in automobile crashes globally.
Thirty five,
38,
40,000
die every year in the United States,
so the one opportunity that's huge.
That's one of the biggest focus for us
here and mit for people who truly care
about this is to design the autonomous
systems are artificial intelligence
systems that say lies and those systems
help work with deal with or take away
what Nitsa calls the four ds of human
folly,
drunk,
drugged,
distracted,
and drowsy.
Driving autonomous vehicles have the
ability to take away drunk driving,
distracted,
drowsy,
and drugged.
Eliminated car ownership.
So taking shared mobility to another
level,
eliminating car ownership from the
business side has the opportunity to
save people money and increase mobility
and access making vehicles.
Removing ownership makes vehicles more
accessible because the cost of getting
from point a to point b drops an order
to magnitude and the insertion of
software and intelligence into vehicles
makes those vehicles,
makes the idea of transportation.
It makes the way we see moving from a to
point b,
a totally different experience,
much like with our smartphone,
it makes it a personalized,
efficient,
and reliable experience.
Now for the negative view,
for the dystopian view,
eliminate jobs,
any technology throughout its history,
throughout our history of human
civilization has always created fear
that jobs that rely on the prior
technology will be lost.
This is a huge fear,
especially in trucking because so many
people in the United States and across
the rely work in the transportation
industry,
transportation sector,
and the possibility that ai will remove
those jobs has potential catastrophic
consequences.
The idea one that we have to struggle
with in the 21st century of the role of
intelligence systems that aren't human
beings being further and further
integrated into our lives is the idea
that a failure of an autonomous vehicle,
even if they're much rare,
if the.
Even if they're much safer that there is
a possibility for an ai algorithm
designed by probably one of the
engineers in this room will kill a
person where that person would not have
died if they were in control of the
vehicle.
The idea of intelligence system,
one indirect interaction with a human
being killing that human being is one
that we have to struggle with on a
philosophical,
ethical and technological level.
Artificial intelligence systems in
popular culture,
less so in engineering concerns may not
be grounded ethically grounded at this
time.
Much of the focus of building these
systems,
as we'll talk about today and throughout
this course that focuses on the
technology,
how do we make these things work,
but of course,
decades out years or decades out,
the ethical concern started rising for
Rodney Brooks,
one of the seminal people from Mit.
Those ethical concerns will not be an
issue for another several decades,
at least five decades,
but they're still important.
It continues the thought,
the idea of what is the role of Ai in
our society?
When that car gets to make a decision
about human life,
what is it making that decision based
on,
especially when it's a black box,
what is the ethical grounding of that
system?
Does it conform with our social norms?
Does it go,
go,
go against them,
and there's many other concerns?
Security is definitely a big one.
A car this not even artificial
intelligence based the car,
this software base.
As they're becoming more and more
millions,
most of the cars on roads today,
I run by millions of lines of source
code.
The idea that those lines of source code
written again by some of the engineers
in this room get to decide the life of a
human being means then a hacker from
outside of the car can manipulate that
code to also decide the fate of the
human being.
That's a huge concern for us from the
engineering perspective.
The truth is somewhere in the middle we
want to find what is the best positive
way we can build these systems to
transform our society to improve the
quality of life of everyone amongst us,
but there's a grain of salt to the hype
of autonomous vehicles.
We have to remember as we discussed in
the previous lecture,
new will come up again and again.
Our intuition about what is difficult
and what is easy for deep learning for
autonomous systems is flawed.
If we use our infuse ourselves.
In this example,
human beings are extremely good at
driving.
This will come up again and again.
Our intuition has to be grounded in
understanding of what is the source of
data,
what is the annotation,
and what is the approach?
What is the algorithm,
so you have to be careful about using
our intuition,
extending a decades out and making
predictions whether there's towards the
Utopian or dystopian view
and as we'll talk about some of the
advancements of companies working in
this space today,
you have to take what people say in the
media,
what the companies say.
Some of the speakers that will be
speaking at this class say about their
plans for the future and their current
capabilities.
I think us a guide that can provide is
when there's a promise of a future
technology,
future vehicles that are two years out
or more.
That has to be.
That's a very delicate prediction one
that is within a year as we'll give a
few examples today is skeptical.
The real proof comes in actual testing
on public roads or in the most
impressive,
the most amazing.
The reality of it is when it's available
to consumer purchase.
I would like to use Rodney Brooks as a
so it doesn't come from my mouth,
but I happen to agree his prediction is
no earlier than 2032 drivers.
Taxi service in a major US city will
provide arbitrary pickup and drop off
locations fully autonomously.
That's 14 years away and by 2045 it will
do so in multiple cities across the
United States.
So think about that,
that a lot of the engineers working in
this space,
a lot of folks are actually building
these systems,
agree with this idea,
and that is the earliest I believe this
will happen and Rodney believes,
but
as all technophobes have been wrong,
it could be wrong.
This is a map on the x axis,
a plot on the x axis of time throughout
the 20th century and the adoption rate
on the y axis from zero to 100 percent
of the various technologies from
electricity to cars to radio,
the telephone and so on.
And as we get closer to today,
the technology adoption rate,
when it goes from zero to 100 percent,
the number of years it takes to adopt
that technology is getting shorter and
shorter and shorter.
As a society,
we're better at throwing away the
technology evolved and accepting of
technology of new.
So if a brilliant idea to solve some of
the problems were discussing comes
along,
it could change everything overnight.
So let's talk about different approaches
to autonomy.
We'll talk about sensors afterwards.
We'll talk about companies,
players in this space,
and then we'll talk about ai and the
actual algorithms and how they can help
solve some of the problems with
autonomous vehicles.
Levels of autonomy.
Here's a useful
taxonomies of levels of autonomy,
useful for initial discussion,
for legal discussion and for policy
making and for blog posts.
The media reports,
but it's not useful.
I would argue for design and engineering
of the underlying intelligence and the
system viewed from a holistic
perspective,
the entire thing,
creating an experience that's safe and
enjoyable.
So let's go over those levels.
The five,
the six levels.
This is presented by sae report j three
zero,
one six.
The most widely accepted taxonomists
nation of autonomy.
No automation at level zero.
Level one and level two is increasing
levels of automation.
Level one is cruise control,
level two is adaptive cruise control and
lane keeping.
Level three,
I don't know what level three is.
There's a lot of people that will
explain that.
Level three is conditional automation,
meaning it's constrained to certain
geographical location.
I will explain that from an engineer
perspective.
I'm a personally a little bit confused
on where that stands.
I'll try to redefine how we should view
automation.
Level four and level five is high full
level automation.
Level four is when the vehicle can drive
itself fully for part of the time.
There's certain areas in which you can
take care of everything no matter what.
No human inter interaction input
safekeeping as required.
Level five,
automation is the car does everything.
Everything.
I would argue that those levels aren't
useful for designing systems that
actually work in the real world.
I would argue that there's two systems,
but first a starting point that every
system to some degree involves a human.
It starts with manual control from a
human human getting in the car and a
human electing to do something so that's
the manual control.
What we're talking about.
When the human engages the system,
when the system is first available and
the human chooses to turn it on,
that's one we have to ai systems,
human centered autonomy,
when the human is needed is involved and
full autonomy.
When ai is fully responsible for
everything from the legal perspective,
that means a two full autonomy means the
car they designer,
the AI system is liable,
is responsible,
and for the human center of autonomy,
the human is responsible.
What does this practically mean for
human centered autonomy,
and we'll discuss examples of all of
these.
When a human interaction is necessary.
The question then becomes is how often
is the system available?
Is it available on in traffic
conditions,
so for traffic,
bumper to bumper is available on the
highway.
Is that sensor based like in the Tesla
vehicle,
meaning based on the visual
characteristics to the scene,
the vehicle is confident enough to be
able to control,
to make control decisions,
perception control decisions.
The other factor not discussed enough
and I think poorly imprecisely discussed
when it is,
is the number of seconds given to the
driver,
not guaranteed,
but provided as a sort of feature to the
driver to take over and the Tesla
vehicle in all vehicles on the road
today,
that time is zero.
Zero seconds of guaranteed zero seconds
have provided.
There is some,
there is some room and sometimes it's
hundreds of milliseconds,
sometimes it's multiple seconds,
but really there's no standard of how
many seconds you get to say wake up,
take control.
Then tele operation,
something that some of the companies
will mention are playing with is when a
human being as involved remotely
controlling the vehicle remotely,
so being able to take over control of
the vehicle when you're,
uh,
when you're not able to control it.
So support by human that's not inside
the car.
That's a very interesting idea to
explore.
But for the human centered autonomy
side,
all of those features and not required,
they're not guaranteed the human driver,
the human inside the car is always
responsible.
At the end of the day,
they must pay attention to a degree
that's required to take over.
When the system fails and no matter
under this consideration,
under this level of autonomy,
the system will fail at some point.
That is the,
that is the point.
That is the collaboration between human
and robot is the system will fail and
the human has to catch one that does.
And then full autonomy is ai is fully
responsible,
not that doesn't.
Again,
as we will present some companies in the
marketing material and that pr side of
things,
they might present that there is
significant degrees of autonomy.
If you're talking about l three or l
four or l five,
you have to read between the lines.
You're not allowed to have tele
operation.
If a human is remotely operating the
vehicle,
a humanist still in the loop,
a humanness still evolved.
It's still a human centered and autonomy
system.
You don't get the ten second rule,
which is ge just because you give the
driver 10 seconds to take control.
That somehow removes liability for you.
If you say that that's it.
As an AI system,
I can't take a can't resolve,
can't deal,
can't control the vehicle in this
situation,
and you have 10 seconds to take over,
that's not good enough.
The driver might be sleeping.
That driver may have had a heart attack.
They're not able to control the vehicle.
Full autonomous systems might must find
safe harbor.
That must get you full.
Stop from point a to point b.
That point b might be your desired
destination or it might be a safe
parking lot,
but it has to bring you to a safe
location.
This is a clear definition of the two
systems and the human.
Of course,
as far as our certain.
A current conception of artificial
intelligence in cars today is a human
always overrides the AI system,
so we should for the for the in the
general case,
the human gets to choose to take
control.
The Ai can't take controls any human
except when danger is imminent,
meaning sudden crashes like an ab
events.
We're not yet ready for AI systems to
say as a society to say,
no,
no.
You're drunk.
You can't drive.
So beyond the traditional levels from
level zero to level five,
the starting point is level zero,
no automation.
All cars start here.
Level one,
level two and level three,
I would argue fall into human senator
autonomy systems,
a one
because they involve some degree of a
human.
Now four or five to some degree,
there's some crossover fall into full
autonomy,
even though with all four,
with way Mo,
as you can ask on Friday and anyone
cruise uber playing in this space,
there's very often a human driver
involved.
One of the huge accomplishments of waymo
over the past month.
Incredible accomplishment.
We're in Phoenix,
Arizona.
They drove without the car,
drove without a driver.
The meaning there was no safety driver
to catch.
There is no engineer staff member there
to catch the car.
A human being that doesn't work for
Google or Waymo got into that car and
got from a to point b without a safety
driver.
That's an incredible accomplishment and
that particular trip was a fully
autonomous trip.
That is full autonomy when there's no
human to catch the car.
No Ai presentation is good without cats.
So full autonomy.
A two system is when you do nothing but
write along.
Human centered autonomy system is when
you have some control.
I'm sorry,
I had to.
So the two paths for autonomous systems,
they want an a two in blue.
On the left is a one human centered,
on the right is a two full autonomy
and then blue is from the artificial
intelligent perspective is easy,
easier,
and then red is harder,
meaning we do not have to achieve 100
percent accuracy.
Harder means everything that's off of
100 percent accuracy,
no matter how small has a potential of
costing human lives and huge amounts of
money for companies.
So let's discuss.
We'll discuss later in the lecture about
the algorithms behind each of these
methods and the left and the right,
but this summarizes the two approaches,
the localization mapping for the car to
determine where it's located.
For the human centered autonomy,
it's easy.
It still has to do the perception it has
to localize itself within the lane.
It has defined all the neighboring
pedestrians in the vehicles in order to
be able to control the vehicle to some
degree,
but because the human is there,
it doesn't have to do so perfectly when
it fails.
A humans there to catch it.
Seen understanding,
perceiving everything in the environment
from the camera,
from law,
whether it's Lidar,
radar,
ultrasonic,
the planning of the vehicle,
whether it's just staying within lane,
uh,
for adaptive cruise control,
controlling the longitudinal movement of
the vehicle,
or it's changing lanes at the Tesla
autopilot or higher degrees of
automation.
All of those movement planning decisions
can be made autonomy.
When the human is there to catch,
it's easier because you're allowed to be
wrong.
Rarely but wrong.
The hard part is getting the human robot
interaction piece right.
That's next Wednesday lecture as we'll
discuss about how deep learning can be
used to interact first.
Perceive everything about the driver and
second to interact with the driver.
That part is hard because he can't screw
up on that part.
You have to make sure you help the
driver know where your flaws are so they
can take over.
If the driver's not paying attention,
you have to bring their attention back
to the road,
back to the interaction.
You have to get that piece right because
for a flawed system,
one that's rarely flawed.
The rarities,
the challenge in fact has to get the
interaction right and then the final
piece is communication.
The autonomous vehicle,
fully autonomous vehicle must
communicate extremely well with the
external world,
with a pedestrian is the Jay Walker's
the humans in this world.
The cyclists that that communication
piece one,
at least that is part of a safe and
enjoyable driving experience,
is extremely difficult on the Ta Waymo
vehicle.
I wish them luck if they come to Boston.
I'm getting from point a to point b
because pedestrians will take advantage
of vehicle must assert itself in order
to be able to navigate Boston streets
and that assertion is communication.
That piece is extremely difficult for a
tesla vehicle for for a a human centered
autonomy vehicle.
L Two l three.
The way you deal with Boston pedestrians
is you take over,
roll down the window,
yells something,
and then speed up getting the piece for
an artificial intelligence system to
actually be able to accomplish something
like that.
As we'll discuss on the ethics side and
the engineering side is extremely
difficult.
That said,
most of the literature and the human
factors field and the autonomous vehicle
field,
anyone that's studied autonomy in
aviation and in vehicles is extremely
skeptical about a human centered
approach they think is deeply
irresponsible,
is deeply irresponsible because is as
argued because human beings,
when you give them a technology which
will take control part of the time,
they'll get lazy.
They would take advantage of that
technology.
They will overtrust that technology.
They'll assume a work perfectly always.
This is the idea that this is this idea
extended beyond further and further
means that the better the system gets,
the better of the car,
it gets a driving itself.
The more the humans will sit back and be
completely distracted.
It will not be able to reengage
themselves in order to safely catch when
the system fails.
This is Chris Urmson,
the founder of the Google self driving
cars program,
and now the co founder of one of the
other co founder is a speaker.
This class on next Friday,
Sterling Anderson have a company called
Aurora,
a startup.
He was one of the big proponents,
or the I should say,
our opponents of the idea that human
centered autonomy could work.
They tried it publicly,
spoken about the fact that Google,
as in the early self driving car
program,
they've tried shared autonomy.
They've tried l two and it failed
because they're engineers that people
driving their vehicles fell asleep and
that's the belief that people have and
we'll talk about why that may not be
true.
There's a fascinating truth in the way
human beings can interact with
artificial intelligence systems that may
work.
In this case,
as I mentioned,
it's the human robot interaction,
building that deep connection between
human and machine of understanding of
communication.
This is what we believe happens,
so there's a lot of videos like this as
a it's,
it's fun,
but it's also representative of what
what society believes happens when
automation is allowed to enter the human
experience and driving where the human
life is a steak that you can become
completely disengaged.
Hmm.
It's kind of.
It's kind of a natural thing to think,
but the question is,
does this actually happened?
What actually happens on public roads,
the amazing thing that people don't
often talk about
is that there is hundreds of thousands
of vehicles on the road today,
equipped with autopilot,
Tesla,
autopilot that have a significant degree
of autonomy.
That's data,
that's information so we can answer the
question what actually happens.
So many of the people behind this team
of instrumented 25 vehicles,
21 of which are Tesla,
autopilot vehicles now with over
collected recording everything about the
driver,
two cameras to hd,
cameras on the driver,
two cameras on the a one,
the camera on the external roadway and
collecting everything about the car,
including audio,
the state,
the pulling,
everything from the Cambus,
the kinematics of the vehicle,
Imu,
gps,
all of that information over now over
300,000
miles,
over 5 billion video frames.
All as we'll talk about,
analyze the computer vision.
You extract from that video of the
driver of everything they're doing.
That level of distraction,
the allocation of attention,
the drowsiness,
emotional states,
the hands on,
we'll hands off,
we'll body pose,
I activity,
smartphone usage,
all of these factors,
all of these things that you would think
would fall apart when you start letting
autonomy into your life.
We'll talk about what the initial
reality is.
That should be inspiring and thought
provoking,
as I said,
three cameras,
single board computer recording all the
data over a thousand machines in holyoke
and distributed computation,
running the deep learning algorithms
I've had mentioned on these five plus
billion video frames going from the raw
data to the actionable useful
information.
The slides are up online if you'd like
to look through them,
I'll fly through some of them and this
is the video of one of thousands of
trips.
We have an autopilot in our data,
a car driving autonomously,
large fraction of the time on highways
from here to California.
I'm here to Chicago,
to Florida and all across the United
States.
We take that data and using the
supervised learning algorithms,
semi-supervised.
The number of frames here is huge for
those that work in computer vision.
Five billion frames is several orders of
magnitude larger than any data set that
people are working with in computer
vision,
actively annotated,
so we want to use that data for
understanding the behavior of what
people are actually doing in the cars
and we want to train the algorithms,
the do perception and control.
A quick summary over 300,000
miles,
25 vehicles.
The color is a true to the actual colors
of the vehicles,
a little fun fact.
Tesla model x model less and now a model
three,
500,500
plus miles a day and growing.
Now,
most days in 2018 are over a thousand
miles a day.
This is a quick gps map in red is manual
driving across the Boston area and Blue
Cyan is autonomous driving.
This is giving you the sense of just the
scope of this data.
This is a huge number of miles with
automated driving,
several orders of magnitude larger than
what Waymo is doing that what cruises
doing,
what Uber is doing.
The miles driven in this data with
autopilot confirming what are.
Y'All must [inaudible] stated it's 33
percent of miles driven autonomously.
This is a remarkable number for those of
you who drive and for those of you who
are familiar with these technologies,
that is remarkable adoption rate,
that 33 percent of the miles are driven
in autopilot.
That means these drivers are getting use
out of the system.
It's working for them.
That's an incredible number.
It's also incredible because under the
the decades of literature from aviation
to automation in vehicles to to Chris
Urmson and Waymo,
the belief is such high numbers are
likely to lead to crashes,
two fatalities to at the very least
highly irresponsible behavior.
Drivers overtrusting the systems and
getting in trouble.
We can run the glance classification
algorithms.
Again,
this is for next Wednesday discussion.
The actual algorithm is the algorithm
that tells the region that the driver is
looking at and it's comparing road
instrument cluster,
left rear view center stack,
and right.
Does the allocation of glance change
with autopilot or with manual driving?
It does not appear to have any
significant noticeable way,
meaning you don't start playing chess,
you don't start.
You don't get in the back seat to sleep,
you don't start texting in your smart
phone and watching a movie,
at least in this Dataset,
this promise here for the human centered
approach,
the observation to summarize this
particular data is that people are using
it a lot.
The percentage of miles and percentage
of hours is incredibly high,
at least relative to what was it will be
expected from these systems and given
that there's no crashes,
there's no near crashes in autopilot.
The road type is mostly highway
traveling at high speeds.
The mental engagement looked at
8,000
trestles of control from machine to
human,
so human beings taking control of the
vehicle saying,
you know what?
I'm going to take control now.
I'm not comfortable with the situation
for whatever reason either not
comfortable or electing to do something
that the vehicle is not able to like
turn off the highway,
make a right or left turn stop for a
stop sign.
These kinds of things.
Physical engagement,
as I said,
glance remains the same and what do we
take from this?
It says something that I'd like to
really emphasize this.
We've talked to,
we talk about autonomous vehicles in
this class and the guest speakers who
are all on the other side,
so I'm representing the human center
side.
Most all our speakers are focused on the
full autonomy side because that's the
side roboticist know how to solve.
That's the fascinating algorithm nerd
side,
and that's the side I love as well.
It's just my belief stands that the
solving the perception control problem
is extremely difficult and two,
three decades away.
So in the meantime we have to utilize
the human robot interaction to actually
bring these ai systems onto the road to
successfully operate and the way we do
that counterintuitively is we have to
have.
We have to let the artificial
intelligence systems reveal their flaws.
One of the most endearing things to
human beings can do to each other.
Friends is revealed their flaws to each
other.
Now,
from an automotive perspective,
from a company perspective is perhaps
not appealing for an ai system to reveal
what it sees about the world and would
it doesn't see about the world where it
succeeds and where it fails,
but that is perhaps exactly what it
needs to do.
In the case of autopilot,
the way the very limited,
but I believe successful way it's
currently doing that is allowing you to
use autopilot basically anywhere,
so what people are doing is they're
trying to engage their turn on autopilot
in places where they really shouldn't.
Rural rural roads,
curvy with terrible road markings with a
in heavy rain conditions with snow,
with lots of cars driving at high speeds
all around.
They turn autopilot on to understand,
to experience the limitations of the
system,
to to interact.
That human robot interaction is through
it's tactile.
By turning it on and seeing is it going
to work here?
How's it going to fail?
And the human is always there to catch
it.
That interaction,
that's communication,
that intimate understanding is what
creates successful integration of ai in
the car.
Before we're able to solve the full
autonomy puzzle.
Learn the limitations by exploring it
starts with this guy and hundreds of
others.
If you search on Youtube,
first time with the autopilot,
the amazing experience of direct
transfer,
of control of your life to an artificial
intelligence system in this case,
given control to Tesla autopilot system.
This is why in the human centered camp
of autonomy,
I believe that autonomous vehicles can
be viewed as personal robots with which
you build,
build a relationship or the human robot
interaction is the key problem,
not the perception control
and they're the flaws of both humans and
machines must be clearly communicated
and perceived perceived because he used
the computer vision algorithms to detect
everything about the human and
communicated because on the displays of
the car or even through voice,
it has to be able to reveal when it
doesn't see different aspects of the
scene from the human centered approach,
then we can focus on the left,
the perception and control side.
Perceiving everything about the external
environment and controlling the vehicle
without having to worry about being 99
point nine,
nine,
nine percent correct.
Approaching 100 percent correct because
in the cases where it's extremely
difficult,
we can let the human catch the system,
we can reveal the flaws and let the
human takeover on the system can't.
So let's get to the sensors,
the sources of raw data that we'll get
to work with.
There's three.
There's cameras,
so image sensors,
rgb infrared,
visual data.
There's radar and ultrasonic and there's
lidar.
Let's discuss the strengths first.
Discuss really what these sensors are,
the strength and weaknesses and how they
can be integrated together for sensor
fusion,
so radar is the trust of the old trusted
friend.
The sensor that's commonly available in
most vehicles that have a degree of
autonomy on the left is a visualization
of the kind of data on high resolution
rate or that's able to be extracted.
It's cheap.
Both radar which works with
electromagnetic waves and ultrasonic,
which works with sound waves,
sending a wave,
letting it bounce off the obstacles,
knowing the speed of that wave,
being able to calculate the distance to
the obstacle based on that,
it does extremely well in challenging
weather,
rain,
snow.
The downside is a slow resolution
compared to the other senses we'll
discuss,
but it is the one that's most reliable
and using automotive industry today and
it's the one that's in sense of fusion
is always there.
Lidar visualized on the right.
The downside is it's expensive,
but it produces an extremely accurate
depth information and a high resolution
map of the environment that has 360
degrees of visibility.
It has some of the big strengths of
radar in terms of reliability,
but with much higher resolution and
accuracy.
The downside is cost.
Here's a quick visualization comparing
the two of the kind of information and
get to work with the.
The density and the quality of
information with Lidar is much higher
and lighter has been the successful
source of ground truth.
The reliable sensor relied upon on
vehicles that don't care about cost
and camera.
The thing that most people here should
be passionate about because machine
learning,
deep learning,
the most ability to have a significant
impact there.
Why versus cheap,
so it's everywhere.
Second is the highest resolution,
so there's the most,
the most highly dense amount of
information,
which means information is something
that can be learned and inferred to
interpret the external scene.
So that's why it's the best source of
data for understanding the scene.
And the other reason it's awesome for
deep learning is because of the hugeness
of data involved,
the,
it's many orders of magnitude more data
available for driving in camera,
visible light or infrared than it is in
Lidar.
Uh,
the.
And our world is designed for visible
light.
Our eyes work in similar ways,
the cameras at least crudely.
So the source data is similar.
The lane markings,
the traffic size of traffic lights,
the other vehicles,
the other pedestrians all operate with
each other in this rgb space.
In terms of visual characteristics,
the downside is cameras are bad at depth
estimation,
it's noisy and difficult even with
stereo vision cameras to estimate depth
relative to lidar and they're not good
and extreme weather and they're not good
at least visible light cameras at night.
So let's compare the ranges.
Here's a plot and meters on the x axis
of the range.
And Acuity on the y axis with ultrasonic
lidar radar and camera passive visual
sensor plotted the range of cameras as
the greatest this is looking at.
We're going to look at several different
conditions.
This is for clear well lit conditions,
so during the day,
no rain,
no fog,
lidar and radar have a smaller range
under 200 meters and ultrasonic sensors
used mostly for park assistance and
these kinds of things.
And blind spot warning has terrible
range,
is designed for extremely close as high
resolution distance estimation for
extremely close distances here,
a little bit small,
but looking at up top is clear.
Well lit conditions the plow would just
looked at and I'm bottom is clear dark
conditions,
so just a clear night day,
no rain but it's night.
And on the bottom right is heavy rain.
Snow or fog.
Vision falls in terms of range and
accuracy under dark conditions and in
rain,
snow or fog radar.
Our old trusted friend stay strong.
The same range just under 200 meters and
at the same acuity,
same with sonar.
Lighter works well at night,
but it does not do well with rain or fog
or snow.
One of the biggest downsides of lighter
other than cost.
So here's another interesting way to
visualize this that I think is
productive far discussion of which
sensor will win out.
Is that the ell musk prediction of
camera or is it the way more prediction
of Lidar for lidar in this kind of plot
that will look for every single sensor,
the greater the radius of the blue,
the more successful that sensor is that
accomplishing that feature with a bunch
of features lined up around the circle,
so range for lighter is pretty good,
not great,
but pretty good.
Resolution is also pretty good.
It works in the dark.
It works in bright light,
but it falls apart in the snow.
It does not provide color information,
texture,
information contrast.
It's able to detect speed,
but the sensor size,
at least to date,
is huge.
The sensor cost,
at least to date,
is extremely expensive and it doesn't do
well in proximity.
We're ultrasonic shines.
Speaking of which,
ultrasonic,
same kind of plot does well in proximity
detection.
It's cheap,
the cheapest sensor or the four and
census size.
You can get it to be tiny.
It works in snow,
fog and rain,
but it's resolution is terrible.
It's range is nonexistent and it's not
able to detect speed.
That's where radar steps up.
It's able to detect speed.
It's also cheap.
It's also small,
but the resolution is very low and it's
just like lidar is not able to provide
texture.
Information,
call information camera.
The sensor costs is cheap.
The sensor size is small,
not good up close proximity.
The range is the longest of all of them.
Resolution is the best of all of them.
It doesn't work in the dark.
It works in bright light,
but not always.
One of the biggest downfalls of cameras
sensors is the sensitivity to lighting
variation.
It works.
It doesn't work in the snow.
Fog,
rain so suffers much like lidar from
that,
but it provides rich,
interesting textural information.
The very kind that deep learning needs
to make sense of this world.
So let's look at the cheap sensors.
Ultrasonic radar and cameras,
which is one approach.
Putting a bunch of those in the car and
fusing them together,
the cost there is low.
One of the nice ways to visualize using
this visualization technique when
they're fused together on the bottom,
it gives you a sense of them working
together to compliment each other's
strengths and the question is where the
camera or lidar will win out for partial
autonomy or full autonomy on the bottom,
showing this kind of visualization for a
lidar sensor and on top showing this
kind of visualization for fused radar,
ultrasonic and camera.
At least under these considerations,
the fusion of the cheap sensors can do
as well as lighter.
Now,
the open question is whether the Lidar
and the future of this technology can
become cheap and it's ranged,
can increase [inaudible].
Then Lidar can win out solid state lidar
and a lot of developments with a lot of
startup ladder companies are promising
to decrease the costs and increase the
range of the sensors,
but for now we plow long dedication on
the camera front.
The annotated driving data grows
exponentially.
More and more people are beginning to
annotate and study the particular
driving perception and control problems
and the very algorithms for the
supervisor and semi-supervised and
generative networks that we use to work
with this data are improving.
So it's a race and of course radar and
ultrasonic.
I was there to help,
so companies that are playing in this
space,
some of them are speaking here
waymo in April 2017.
They exited their testing,
their extensive impressive testing
process and allowed the first rider and
Phoenix public rider in November 2017
and it's an incredible accomplishment
for our company and for an artificial
intelligence system in November 2017.
No safety driver.
So the car truly achieved full autonomy
and there are a lot of constraints,
but it's full autonomy.
It's a step.
It's an amazing step in the direction
towards full autonomy much sooner than
people would otherwise predict.
And the miles,
4 million miles driven autonomously by
November 2017 and growing quickly
growing in terms of full autonomous
driving,
if I can say so cautiously because most
of those miles have a safety driver.
So I would argue it's not full autonomy,
but however they define full autonomy,
it's 4 million miles driven,
incredible uber in terms of miles second
on that list,
they have driven 2 million miles
autonomy by December of this of last
year,
2017,
the quiet player here in terms of not
making any declarations of being fully
autonomous,
just quietly driving in a human centered
way.
L Two over 1 billion miles in autopilot.
Over 300,000
vehicles today are equipped with
autopilot technology,
with the ability to drive control the
car laterally and longitudinally.
And if anyone believes the CEO of Tesla,
there'll be over 1 million such vehicles
by the end of 2018.
But no matter what,
the 300 thousands and incredible number
and the 1 billion miles is an incredible
number.
Autopilot was first released in
September 2014,
one of the first systems on the road to
do so autopilot.
And I caught myself as one of the
skeptics in October 2016.
Autopilot decided to let go of an
incredible work done by Mobileye.
Now Intel,
we're designing their perception control
system.
They decided to let go of it completely
and start from scratch using mostly deep
learning methods that drive px to system
from Nvidia and eight cameras.
They decided to start from scratch.
That's the kind of boldness,
the kind of risk taking.
They can come with naivety,
but in this case it worked incredible.
A eight system is going to be released
at the end of 2018 and this promising
one of the first vehicles that's
promising what they're calling l and the
definition of l three,
a coordinated Thorston Lionheart,
the head of the automated driving an
Audi,
and Audi is one of the function is
operating as intended if the customer
turns the traffic jam pilot on.
Now this l three system is designed only
for traffic jams,
bumper to bumper traffic under 60
kilometers an hour.
If the customer turns the traffic jam
pilot on and uses it as intended,
and the car was in control at the time
of the accident,
the driver goes to the insurance company
and the insurance company will
compensate the victims of the accident
and aftermath.
They come to us,
we will pay them.
So that means the car is liable.
The problem is under the definition of
l,
two l three,
perhaps there is some truth to this
being an l three system.
The important thing here is nevertheless
less deeply and fundamentally human
centered because even as you see here in
this demonstration video with a
reporter,
the car for a poorly understood reason,
transfer control to the driver says,
that's it,
I can't.
I can't take care of the situation.
You take control.
How,
how much time do you have in terms of
seconds before you really need to know
to take over?
Well,
this is the new thing about level three.
With level three,
the system allows the driver to give the
prompt to take over vico control again
ahead of time,
which is in this case up to 10 seconds.
Okay,
so if the traffic jam situation clears
up or anything,
she failed her in the system careers,
everything you might think of,
the system still needs to be able to dry
automatically because it's a driver has
this time to take over.
You might ask them,
what is new about this?
So why is he saying this is the first
level three system worldwide on the
market when talking about these levels
of automation,
there's a classification which starts as
low as zero,
which is basically the driver's doing
everything,
there's no assistance,
nothing.
And then it gradually becomes into
partly automation and when we're talking
about these assistants functions like
lay,
keeping a distance,
keeping a,
we're talking about level two assistants
functions,
which is um,
meaning that the driver is obliged to
permanently monitored the traffic
situation to keep the hands on the wheel
even though there's the support and
assistance and to intervene immediately
if anything is not quite right.
So you know that from living assistance
systems when the steering is not
perfectly in the right lane,
you have to intervene and correct
immediately.
And that is the main difference.
Now we gotta take over the crest.
So what,
so let's,
let's talk about what
that means.
This is still a human center system is
still struggles.
It's still must solve the human robot
interaction problem
and there's many others playing in the
space and they on the full autonomy
side,
Waymo,
uber,
GM cruise Yutani.
The CTO,
which we'll speak here on Tuesday,
optimists ride is annuity voyage,
the CEO of which we'll speak here next
Thursday,
and Aurora not listed,
the the founder of which we'll speak
here next Friday,
and the human centered autonomy side.
The reason I am a speaking about us so
much today is we don't have any
speakers.
I'm the speaker.
The Tesla autopilot is for several years
now doing incredible work on that side.
We're also working with Volvo pilot
assist as a lot of different approaches.
They're more conservative.
Interesting.
The audio traffic jam assist,
as I mentioned,
the eight being released at the end of
this year.
I'm the Mercedes drive politest system.
The eclass an interesting vehicle that I
got to drive quite a bit as the Cadillac
Super Cruise.
The ct six,
which is very much constrained
geographically to highway driving and
the loudest.
Proudest of the mall.
George Hotz of the.
I opened pilot.
Let's just leave that there,
so where can ai help?
We'll get into the details of the coming
lectures on each individual component.
I'd like to get some examples.
The key areas,
problem spaces that we can use machine
learning to solve from data is
localization and mapping,
so being able to localize yourself in
the space,
very first question,
that robot and use to answer,
where am I seeing understanding,
taking the scene in and interpreting
that scene,
detecting all the entities in the scene,
detecting the class of those entities in
order to then do movement planning to
move around those entities.
And finally,
driver's state essential element for the
human robot interaction.
Perceive everything about the driver,
everything about the pedestrians and the
cyclists and the cars outside the human
element of those,
the human perception side.
So first the,
where am I?
Visual adometry using cameras sensors,
which is really where,
once again,
deep learning is most,
uh,
the vision sensor is the most amenable
to learning based approaches.
And visual adometry is using camera to
localize yourself.
To answer the where am I question the
traditional approaches slam detect
features in the scene and track them
through time from frame to frame.
And from the movement of those features
are able to estimate a thousands of
features.
Tracking,
estimate the location,
the orientation of the vehicle or the
camera.
Those methods was stereo.
Vision first requires taking two camera
streams on distorting them.
Competing disparity map from the
different perspectives,
the two camera computing,
the matching between the two,
the feature detection,
the sift to fast or any of the methods
of extracting non deep learning methods
of extracting features,
strong detectable features that can be
tracked through from frame to frame,
tracking those features and estimating
the trajectory,
the orientation of the camera.
That's the traditional approach to
visual odometry in the recent years
since 2015,
but most success in the last year has
been the end to end.
Deep learning approaches either Stereo
monocular cameras.
Deep Vo is one of the most successful.
The ntn methods is taken a sequence of
images extracting with a CNN from each
image,
the central features from each image,
and then using rnn recurrent neural
network to track over time the
trajectory,
the pose of the camera image to pose and
to end.
Here's the visualization on a kitty
dataset using DPO.
Again,
taking the video up on the top right as
an input and estimating,
what's visualized is the position of the
vehicle in red is the estimate based
again end to end with a CNN and rnn.
The in red is the estimate in blue is
the ground truth in the Kitty Dataset,
so this removes a lot of the modular
parts of Slam,
a visual adometry and allows it to be
end to end,
which means it's learnable,
which means it gets better with data.
That's huge
and that's vision alone.
This is one of the exciting
opportunities for ai or people working
in ai is the ability to use a single
sensor and perhaps the most inspiring
because that sensor is similar to our
own the sensor that we ourselves use of
our eyes to use that alone as the
primary sensor to control a vehicle.
That's really exciting and the fact that
deep learning that the vision visible
light is the most amenable to deep
learning approaches makes this
particular an exciting area for deep
learning research seen understanding of
course,
who can do a thousand slides on this?
Traditionally,
object detection,
pedestrians,
vehicles,
there is a bunch of different types of
classifiers and feature extraction is
hard like features and deep learning has
basically taken over and dominate every
aspect of scene,
interpretation,
perception,
understanding,
tracking,
recognition,
classification,
detection problems
and audio.
Can't forget audio that we can use audio
as source of information,
whether that's detecting honks or in
this case using the audio of the tires,
microphones on the tires to determine,
visualize.
There's a spectrogram of the audio
coming in.
For those of you who are particularly
have a particularly tuned ear,
can listen to the different audio coming
in here of wet road and drive road after
the rain so there's no rain,
but the road is nevertheless wet and
detecting that as extremely important
for vehicles because they still don't
have traction.
Control is that have poor control in
road to road surface,
tired road surface connection,
and being able to detect that from just
audio is a very interesting approach.
Finally or not.
Finally,
next for the perception control side.
Finally is the movement planning.
Getting from a to point b from point a
to point b.
traditional approaches,
the optimization based approach,
determine the optimal control,
try to reduce the problem,
formalize the problem in a way that's
amenable to optimization based
approaches.
There's a lot of assumptions that need
to be made.
Once those assumptions are made,
you're able to determine to generate
thousands or millions of possible
trajectories and have an objective
function would determine which of the
trajectories to take.
Here's a race car optimizing how to take
a turn at high speed
learning reinforcement,
learning the application you'll know or
it's three enforcement learning is
particularly exciting for both the
control and the planning side,
so that's where the two of the
competitions were doing in this class
coming into play,
the simplistic two dimensional world of
deep traffic and the high high speed
moving.
I risked world of deep crash.
We'll explore those tomorrow.
Tomorrow's lecture is on deeper
enforcement learning and finally
driver's state detecting everything
about the driver and then interacting
with them.
On the left in green are the easier
problems on the right in red are the
harder problems in terms of perception,
in terms of how amenable they are to
deep learning methods.
Body pose estimation is a very well
studied problem.
We have extremely good detectors for
estimating the pose,
the hands,
the elbows,
the shoulders,
every aspect,
visible aspect of the body.
Head pose,
the orientation of the head or extremely
good at that,
and as we get smaller and smaller in
terms of size,
blink rate,
blink duration,
Ipos and bling dynamics start getting
more and more difficult.
All of these metrics,
all of these metrics extremely important
for detecting things like drowsiness or
as components of detecting emotion or
where people are looking and driving
where your head is turned is not
necessarily where you're looking in
regular life.
Non-Driving life.
When you look somewhere,
you usually turn your head to look with
your eyes in driving your head office.
They still or moves very subtly.
Your eyes do a lot more moving.
It's the kind of a effect it would
described as the lizard owl effect.
Some fraction of people,
a small fraction are owls,
meaning they move their head a lot and
some people,
most people are lizards moving eyes to
allocate their attention.
The problem with eyes is from the
computer vision perspective,
they're much harder to detect in
lighting variation in the real world
conditions,
they get harder and we'll discuss how to
deal with it.
Of course,
that's where deep learning steps up and
really helps with real world data.
Cognitive load.
We'll discuss as well as the meeting of
the cognitive load of the driver to
give.
A quick clip is this is the driver
glance I've seen before estimating the
very most important problem on driver
state side is determining whether
they're looking on road or off road.
It's the dumbest,
simplest,
but most important aspect.
Are they looking at are they in the seat
and looking on the road or are they not?
That's driver glance classification.
Not estimating the Xyz geometric
orientation where they're looking,
but actually binary class classification
on road or off road body pose
estimation,
determining of the hands on wheel or not
determining if the body alignment is
standard is good for seatbelt,
for safety.
This is one of the important things for
autonomous vehicles.
If there's an imminent danger to the
driver,
the driver should be asked to return to
a position that is safe for them in a in
case of a crash driver.
Emotion
on the top is a satisfied on the bottom
as a frustrated driver,
they self report as satisfied.
This is what the voice based navigation.
One of the biggest sources of
frustrations for people in cars is voice
based navigation.
Trying to tell an artificial
intelligence system using your voice
alone where you would like to go.
Huge source of frustration.
One of the interesting things in our
large data set that we have from the
effective computing perspective is
determining which of the features are
most commonly associated with frustrated
voice based interaction,
and that's a smile is shown.
There is the counterintuitive notion
that emotion in particular emotion and
the car is very context dependent,
that smiling is not necessarily a sign
of happiness and the stoic board look of
the driver up top is not necessarily a
reflection of unhappiness is indeed a 10
out of 10 in terms of satisfaction with
the experience if he has ever been
satisfied with anything happens to be
Dan Brown,
one of the amazing engineers in our
team,
cognitive load estimating from the eye
region and sequences of images and three
d convolutional neural networks taking
in a sequence of images from the eye,
looking at the blink dynamics in the eye
position to determine the cognitive load
from zero to two,
how deep thought you are.
Two paths to autonomous future.
Again,
I would like to maybe for the last time,
but probably not argue for the one on
the left because our brilliant much
smarter than me.
Guest speakers will argue for the one on
the right.
The human centered approach allows us to
solve the problems in 99 percent
accuracy of localization,
seen understanding,
movement planning.
Those are the problems we're taking on
this class.
The scene segmentation and we'll talk
about on Thursday the control that we'll
talk about tomorrow and then drive our
state that we'll talk about next
Wednesday.
These problems can be solved with deep
learning today.
The problems in the right,
solving them to close to 100 percent
accuracy are extremely difficult and
maybe decades away.
Because for full autonomy to be here,
we have to solve this situation.
I've shown this many times octet
triomphe.
We have to solve this situation.
I give you just a few examples.
What do you do have to solve this
situation?
I sorta subtler situation here is a,
is it busy crosswalk where no autonomous
vehicle will ever have a hope of getting
through unless it asserts itself and I,
there's a couple of vehicles here that
kind of nudged ourselves through or at
least when they have the right of way.
Don't necessarily nudge,
but don't hesitate when a pedestrian is
present.
An ambulance flying by,
even though if you use a trajectory.
So as a pedestrian and intent modeling
algorithm to predict the momentum of the
pedestrian,
uh,
to estimate where they can possibly go,
you would then Thomas vehicle will stop.
But these vehicles don't stop.
They assert themselves,
they move forward.
Now for full autonomy system,
this may not be the last time I showed
this video,
but because it's taking full control,
it's following a reward,
function and objective function and all
of the problems,
the ethical and the ai problems that
arise,
like this close runner problem will
arise.
So we have to solve those problems.
We have to design that objective
function.
So with that,
I'd like to thank you and encourage you
to come tomorrow because you get a
chance to participate in deep traffic,
deep reinforcement learning competition.
Thank you very much.